christian bale reaction to the batman
trailer dub from gom films
george is a man he's the geo in in the g
george so he is a man who i've gotten to
know quite well recently we've talked on
the phone for i'm thinking an
accumulative two hours in total
wonderful gentleman as kind as he sounds
in these videos and he works his butt
off so if you guys haven't seen more of
his trailer dubs they take a long time
to put together in fact he did a live
stream recently showing him live edit
the amount of extensive work that goes
into this is insane and the fact that he
lets us react to his videos i am so
grateful for you george so grateful for
you i will adopt one of your children to
take away some of the financial burdens
in your life
anywho guys let's watch this
[Music]
okay i'm video to watch the batman
preview and i don't know how i feel
about this
actually i can't wait i want this
yes i'm a bad fan okay all right
it was so good
i don't know who this
that is that the joker no wait a minute
no i was so
i don't know what i'm saying
i miss that light
yup i like that very much
where i would ask were she
and the joker would be annoying all you
would say is this
you can't hurt me
i can take care of myself i believe you
can yeah
who are you under there
jordan gordon-levitt
oh nice oh
wait a second i did a scene very similar
to this in the dark knight rises look
oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh please
oh i'm getting flashbacks rachel where
is she
[Applause]
you see you can't kill a batman hey you
want to know a secret you is dead
it looks as good as batman but the
question is can we trust them
mr george you nailed that one that's one
of my favorites that you've done so far
absolutely because yeah but geo he
doesn't do his like he doesn't do the
accents per se but what he's trying to
do from at least from what i gather is
he's trying to match like this some of
the speech pattern and the cadence like
i can imagine him when he's doing the
voiceover work really trying to match
his mouth when he's speaking and
recording to what christian bale is
doing and i've seen a lot of christian
male interviews so no does the voice
sound like his welsh accent no it
doesn't but there is a tone in cadence
that he is pretty much nailing down and
he's got the rhythm down of a lot of
christian bail uh interviews that i've
seen him do so i don't know what
interview this is with you this is like
perfectly matched up it really looks
like he's watching the trailer yeah and
i'm sure he's with him i'm sure it's an
interview being conducted but it looks
like he's watching something yeah
absolutely and i mean you're really good
to it not only taking the cadence and
everything but also just kind of
matching the energy on in the faces of
the people whose clips you've pulled
like here you know kind of going with
his you know he's got this interesting
energy christian bale where he can get
kind of like a little intense but then
he'll you know come back and laugh a
little bit and i feel like you made it
this wonderful uh little gatekeepery
thing almost where he's like you know
obviously anybody who's played batman is
gonna be a harsh critic of the next
person playing batman and i love that
vibe coming off of him too just because
christian bale you know you see him and
he has kind of an intensity so to have
this parody where he's in a much more
fun environment is i don't know this is
really enjoyable to me well he was
saying things that aren't exactly what
christian bale would say but it makes
for a good spoof of the actual christian
bail yeah where a lot of the times what
we've seen with george do like take
chris evans for example is he's not
really going for like how chris evans
would be he's putting like his own
unique personality stamp onto chris
evans this feels like an actual spoof of
if christian bale was watching this
trailer yeah
because christian bale he does have like
that intensity like you were saying but
there also is this observant warmth that
he can provide because he is very deep
and intellectual that's when i was
appreciation about this is because
sometimes when you do these oftentimes
it's like a lot of critical jabs that
you're having the personalities take on
here where christian bale here was
actually coming across a little bit more
receptive towards this which is how he's
been in the media towards robert
pattinson playing the batman so this
actually felt more apt and that's what i
loved about it was it felt like a
natural parody of the actual christian
bale versus like george doing some like
you know like like jabs yeah instead of
going full on into the competitive
nature it's like there's a little bit of
that in there especially like with the
batmobile versus the tumbler and all
that but yeah i think you you nailed it
where it really does look like he's just
watching and getting into the trailer
yeah and that's a special thing that
highlights both your
you know impression but also your choice
of clip because you know there's a
million interviews you could have pulled
from and this one seems like the perfect
one to match this you know sketch that
you've made out of it well christian
bale in interviews he but naturally his
body language he can be he can go from
really focused to like wide-eyed a lot
of the time and but he's he's very
invested so he makes for a great
spoof-like video for something like this
i know people click on this and get
upset because they don't read the whole
sentence that says dub yeah that's on
you
yeah
don't rob yourself of fun just because
of a semantic thing yeah that's that's
not on george and obviously they take a
lot of time to put together so please
subscribe to george another killer video
i could see why it's such a hit guys you
can subscribe to us hit that like button
check us out on patreon last night at
least to a peak
fox just wanted to shout you out because
you know if anybody would be the
catwoman selena kyle cat thief burglar
of this channel it would be you very
happy to have you back in the psych
comments over on patreon warms my heart
the why would she be the cow
because
fox much like we established in the
previous shout out is probably the most
physically fit and capable fighter among
our patrons and thus she could strike
out into the streets mix those skills
with stealth maybe don some kind of
latex leather or other type of spandexy
cat suit conor thief
but you know she steals our hearts with
her generosity and that's quick yeah
yeah it's quick it's part of your shout
out that's quick that's a nugget because
this is so quick wonderful soul that's
john do it quickie john swooping with
the ladies
finish fast and yep finish fast quick
johnny man john